Welcome to our fifth lecture in person for Stanford Deep Learning CS230.
Today's lecture is going to be about deep reinforcement learning. I actually switched
the original plan of talking about neural network interpretability and LLM visualization
simply because you haven't had the chance to study attention maps, convolutional neural
networks, and so it would have been an overkill to do that week five. So we're going to talk about
neural network interpretability and visualization in a later lecture, actually. But today our
focus will be on deep reinforcement learning, which is probably my favorite lecture of the
class. I feel like I say that every week, but it's okay. I like it. The agenda is pretty packed.
We're going to start with deep reinforcement learning, which you can think of as the marriage
between deep learning and reinforcement learning. Together the baby is called deep reinforcement
learning and we're going to see how reinforcement learning works and how neural networks can play
a part in building a reinforcement learning agent. In the second half of the class,
we will focus on a very specific concept called reinforcement learning
from human feedback that you might have heard of. It's one of the core concepts that
really made the difference between what you might have remembered as GPT-2
and chat GPT. That's the leap. That's really the technique that has democratized
access to LLM because of the performance improvements and the alignment with humans.
So we're going to see what is this concept of our LHF and how does it work and why does it
allow us to align a language model to human preferences. Ready to go? As always,
let's try to make it interactive. So the motivation behind deep reinforcement learning
and as usual, you're going to have all the most important papers that are covered in the
class listed at the bottom of each slide. Reinforcement learning has grown in popularity.
One of the very popular papers called human level control through deep reinforcement learning
is the work from DeepMind that has shown us that a single algorithm training method
can allow us to train AI that can play many, many Atari games better than humans.
Single algorithm over 40, 50 games where it exceeds human capability, which is quite
impressive when you thought about the fact that machine learning used to be niche and you
would have to train a really niche algorithm to perform different tasks. Here's an algorithm
that can just learn sort of every Atari game. A little later, you might have heard of
AlphaGo. AlphaGo is an algorithm that was developed to beat and exceed
human performance in the game of Go. We'll talk about it a little more.
The game of Go is a very complex game. Some would argue way more complex than chess
from a decision-making standpoint and from the possibilities that can happen on the board.
So it actually got sold in 2017 again by the DeepMind team and David Silver's lab.
Later on and again another great paper from DeepMind had showed us that reinforcement
learning can also be used for strategy game that might be a touch more complex than chess
or Go that might actually involve multiple players playing with each other or against
each other. Some of you might have played StarCraft for example. That's an example of a game
where it requires a lot of long-term thinking, short-term thinking. Another one is Dota.
Some of you might have played Dota or League of Legends where you have a team playing
against another team. Those are examples of games that involve multiple agents playing
collaboratively. It's pretty hard to develop systems that can play with each other against
multiple opponents. Finally, most recently this is 2022 so alongside the release of ChatGPT
this paper that introduces the concept of reinforcement learning with human feedback
applied to aligning language models with human preferences. We'll talk about that later.
All this to say that reinforcement learning allowed us to exceed human performance in a variety of
tasks. The first one I want us to think about is the game of Go. Let's say that you were asked
to solve the game of Go with classic supervised learning. Everything we've seen together so far,
labeled data. How would you solve the game of Go with classic supervised learning? What data would
you collect? What would be the label? Good point. You look at history of plenty of games,
hopefully from good players. You look at X as the input being the current state of the board
and Y as the next state of the board. This would tell you what move was selected
and you learn the move essentially. Hopefully, if you do that across many games,
you might see the agent become more attuned to the game and develop better strategies.
Hopefully, it's a professional player. What are the disadvantages of that or the shortcomings
that you can anticipate? You might not see the entire space of possible states of the board,
so you might miss out on a lot of different strategies. The game of Go is actually a game
with two players, one player that uses the black stones and one player that uses the white
stones. Iteratively, they're going to place those stones on the grid, a 13 by 13 grid
that you can see on screen with the goal of surrounding their opponents. You're constantly
trying to surround the stones of the opponent and the opponent is trying to surround your
stones. You can imagine that for every intersection on the grid, there are multiple
possibilities. Either there's a black stone or a white stone or nothing. On a 13 by 13 grid,
you can imagine how many possibilities of a board state there are. It's impossible to capture all
of that with historical moves from professional players. It will just never cover that. The
same thing could be said in chess as well. You know that even the professional players can
plan x number of steps in advance, but nobody knows where the game takes you. In the late
stages of the games or the end games, players always find themselves playing a different game
and that's part of the magic of being good at chess. So yeah, that's a problem. What's
another problem or shortcoming beyond the fact that we can't observe possibly all the states?
Yes. Correct, correct. If I repeat what you said, well first, you don't even know if this
was a good move. So maybe it was not even a good move and you're learning something that
was not a good move and you're labeling it as a good move. And second, you're actually only
getting partial information, meaning you don't have the information of what's in the person's
mind and what strategy they're trying to execute. So you're looking at a single example
among long-term strategy and you can't expect the model to guess what's the long-term
strategy because it was just trained on x and y and matching the inputs to a possible output.
So you don't really have any concept of a strategy at that point. It looks one-off
at every decision of the model. Okay, those are really good points. The other one
is the ground truth might be ill-defined. What I mean by that is even the best humans
in the world do not play their best game every day and even their best game is not
the ground truth. And that creates an issue because you're essentially training against
a target that is off by a certain margin. You're never going to get better than the
best human and the best human is not the best possible existing, the best possible strategy
at every point. So you could argue what if we get a panel of experts that we're monitoring
and those are the best players in the world. Even with a panel of experts that decides
every move, you still have an ill-defined ground truth. So that's a big issue.
Too many states in the game you mentioned and we will likely not generalize, which is what
you said, meaning we're looking at one-off situations. We're not looking at entire
strategies. And so when we face a board state that we've never seen before,
because the model was not trained on strategy, it's sort of we get stuck.
And this is an example of a perfect application for reinforcement learning
because reinforcement learning is all about delayed labels and making sequences of good
decisions. So if you have to remember in one sentence, what's RL? RL is making good
sequences of decisions, sequences of good decisions, sorry, and do that automatically.
Another way to look at it is the difference between, you know, classic supervised learning
and RL is in classic supervised learning you teach by example, in reinforcement learning
you teach by experience, which is also a different concept. You're not just showing
cats and non-cats to a model. You're actually letting the model experience an environment
until it figures out what were the best decision it made and learns from them.
Some examples of reinforcement learning applications. I'm going to mention them.
We have gaming, of course, that we already covered. What are other applications
of AI where we need good sequences of decisions?
Yes. Autonomous driving? Yeah, correct. I mean, in driving, you could argue RL
could work and there's some RL going on. But what you mean, I think, is you have some sort
of a dynamic planning algorithm that allows you to strategize. If you see a red light
ahead, you might start slowing down over time, but maybe it will turn green. So you
might not slow down completely. This is an example of a strategy.
This is an example of a strategy that you need, of course. Yeah.
Robotic controlling. That's a great example also related to autonomous driving. But
imagine you want to teach to a robot to move from point A to point B. The number of good
decisions that the robot needs to make in terms of moving each of their joints
is tremendous. It's actually super unlikely that a robot would move from A to B if it's
not trained to make good sequences of decisions. What else? Actually, the biggest one nobody
mentioned yet. It's not a great application. I don't like it, but it happens to be the
biggest one over enforcement learning. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Advertisement. Yeah. Marketing.
You're right. So yeah, we talked about robotics. Advertisement is another example.
Advertisement is a long game. Companies are showing you multiple ads before you buy.
And in fact, the reason reinforcement learning is important is because
they're planning a strategy that might lead a buyer to execute a purchase over time. And
it requires long-term thinking. So there's a lot of reinforcement learning applied to marketing,
advertisement, real-time bidding processes, et cetera. Okay. Clear on what RLEs and how
it differs from classic supervised learning. So let's put some vocabulary around that concept.
In reinforcement learning, you have an agent and the agent interacts with an environment.
As the agent interacts with the environment, the agent will perform certain actions that we
will denote AT, where T is a time step. And the environment will show you states
that transition from time step T to time step T plus one. So subject to an action AT,
an environment may transition from ST to ST plus one. You can think of the game of Go.
I take the action of putting my Blackstone on a certain grid intersection and the
environment has changed. The state has changed. It moved from state time step T
to time step T plus one where my stone is on the grid. After that state update happens,
there's two things that the agent observes. The agent observes an observation that we will
note OT and a reward RT. Okay. So those are the vocabulary words. And of course,
the goal of the agent will be to maximize the rewards. One thing to know about the
observation, we'll talk about it a little more. The observation sometimes is equal to the state.
Can someone guess why we might need two concepts instead of a single concept?
Why is it important to have a state and an observation? Yes. Yes, correct. So in some
cases, the environment may not be fully transparent to the user. And so for example,
in chess or in Go, the observation is actually equal to the state. You see everything on your
board. All the information is available to you. If you play League of Legends or StarCraft,
you know the concept of, I think in English, it's called like a cloud or a fog. I think it's
a fog. You only see certain parts of the map until you have explored everything or until
your friends are sort of visiting the other parts of the map. And so the observation is
actually less information than the states of the environment. Okay. And then the last piece
of vocabulary is a transition. When I refer to a transition, I refer to the process of getting
from state T to state T plus one, which means we're in state T, the agent takes an action AT,
it observes OT and a reward RT, and it transitions to the next state ST plus one.
Question. Wait, what do you mean? Are there examples of environments where the state
is so large that, yeah, possibly for computational reasons? Yeah. Yeah. You might have
games. I mean, you've got open world games. Like truly you could argue, I don't know,
there are some games where you might press start and you see the entire environment,
but who cares of what's happening 20,000 kilometers west of you, if you're in a
certain location that might not influence your strategy. So you might actually put some sort
of a, you know, trust circle or like some sort of a circle in which you observe,
which you think has 99% of the information you need, possibly for computational reasons.
That's a good point. Okay. Let's get to a practical example of a reinforcement
learning algorithm and develop it together. This example is called recycling is good
because recycling is good, but also because it's a simple example illustrative of reinforcement
learning. So let's say we have a small environment with five states. There is a starting state
marked in brown, which is state two. It's our initial state. And then on the left side,
you have state one, which is a garbage. And it's great to get to the garbage because you're
going to be able to put in the garbage, the, you know, the stuff that you have in your hands,
you know, you're trying to throw away some garbage and the garbage kind of happens to be
there. And so we would expect there to be a reward on the other side. If you actually go
to the right, you might pass by state three, which is empty. You might pass by state four,
where there is a chocolate packaging that is left on the ground that you can pick up.
And it's good to pick it up. And then on stage five, state five, you have the recycle bin,
which is more valuable than the garbage can, because you can recycle and you should get
better rewards for that. So that's our game. In this game, we define a reward that is
associated with the type of behaviors that we want the agents to learn. And the reward is
as follow. That's just one example, plus two for throwing your garbage in the normal can,
plus one for picking up the chocolate packaging, and plus 10 if you manage to make it to the
recycle bin. Is it clear? Now, the goal will be, and that's the case in reinforcement
learning oftentimes, to maximize the return. We define formally the return, but think about
it as maximize the amount of rewards that you get as you go through this journey and
you make your decisions. In this specific game, we have five states, and there's three
types of states. In brown is the initial states. We have normal states, and we have in blue
terminal states. When you get to a terminal state in reinforcement learning, it will typically
end the game. It will end one episode of the game. You move to another episode,
you'll get back to the starting state or initial state, and you'll redo another episode.
The possible actions for agent here are going to be fairly simple, left and right.
And we are going to add an additional rule that is important, which is that the garbage
collector comes in three minutes and it takes a minute to get from one state to the other.
Why is that an important rule to add to the game? Can you guess? Yeah?
Yeah, otherwise you just go back and forth between stage three and stage four. You just
collect a bunch of chocolate packaging and you never make it to the bin. And so it's not what
we want. Okay, so how do we define the long-term return? The long-term return is
going to be defined as capital R, which is the sum of rewards with a discount.
Discount is a very important concept in reinforcement learning. It's also a very
natural concept to think about. Can you think of what the discount would represent for humans?
Do you have an example of what it could be? Yeah, the value of money and time. Exactly.
Or the energy that a robot might have. Things like that. Yeah. You would rather get a dollar
now than a dollar in 10 years, knowing that there is some inflation, for example. That's
the example of a discount in reinforcement learning is the same. Let's say you have a
strategy that takes so much time, you need to discount it because your robot might lose
energy as it's going through it, for example. Discounts can vary, but they stay between zero
and one. What is the best strategy to follow if gamma, the discount, is equal to one? Meaning
time doesn't matter here if it's longer or shorter. I just want to maximize the return.
Best strategy to follow. Let's give it a try. Someone who hasn't spoken yet. Yes. Bounce
around, but remember the rule of three minutes. You can bounce around because you will not get
to the terminal state before the time allotted is done. But that would be a good idea if this
rule was not true. What else could you do? The idea. It's an easy one, no? Not too hard.
Best strategy for gamma equals one. And give me also the maximum reward you would get.
People are sleepy today. Yeah. Go to the recycle. So, right, right,
right. Yeah, that's right. Thank you. Right, right, right. And then what's your total reward?
Yeah, that's right. Eleven. So that's where we get terminal state and we grab our reward of
11. Very good. Now, assuming 0.9 for gamma, we're going to complexify things a little bit.
I'm going to walk you through a very simple algorithm that, you know, allows us to sort
of determine the best strategy and we will put our numbers in a matrix. So, for instance,
we'll define a Q table. And Q stands, you know, it's a value function where the name
Q learning, Q star, you might have heard, all of these things come from Q learning.
And so let's say we have a Q table which has the size of number of states times number of
actions. So five rows, two columns in our case. Every entry of the Q table is essentially
representing how good it is to take action A in state B. Do you agree that if we had a table
with these numbers, essentially we solve the problem. Meaning at any point, the agent can
just look in the table, I am in state three. Let's look at column one that would tell me the
value of action one. And let's see that column two, it will tell me the value of action two.
So I have everything I need to make my decisions. So that table is really the thing you want to
find in this exercise. Now the way we will find the table is sort of using backtracking
algorithm where we might actually codify the environment as a tree and traverse the tree.
So here's what it looks like. I start in S2 and I have two options ahead of me.
I can go to the left where I will get a reward of two. It's an immediate reward.
The immediate reward is not discounted. It's an immediate reward. Remember the formula for r.
The immediate reward r0 is not discounted. That would take me to S1. It's a terminal state
so there's nothing to do after. Second option, I go to the right and I get a reward of zero.
That's my immediate reward and I end up in state three. State three is not a terminal state
so I can go and do the same exercise from state three. In state three I have two options.
I can go to the left where I would see a reward of zero and I will end up in S2
or I will go to the right and I will get an immediate reward of plus one. It's an immediate
reward. We're not discounting it. I will end up in S4 and from S4 again I have two options
back to the left to S3 with zero reward or to the right with the amazing reward of plus 10
and the terminal state of S5. That's my map of immediate rewards. That's not my discounted
return. What we're going to do now is we're going to backtrack up the tree in order to
compute the discounted returns. Actually if I'm in S3 right here I see that I can get an immediate
reward in S4 of plus one and I want to compute my maximum return that I can get from when I'm
in S3. My maximum return is that in S4 I could get a plus 10 but I need to discount that.
My discount is 0.9 so I multiply 10 by 0.9. What it tells me is that from S4 I can expect nine
plus one which I get as an immediate reward from moving from S3 to S4. I can update this number
to 10 meaning from S3 the best you can hope for is a discounted return of 10 which is one
plus 0.9 times 10. Everyone follows? Now let's do the same exercise one step before in S2.
In S2 I have an immediate reward of zero for going to S3 or an immediate reward of two for
going to S1. S1 is not going to be worth it. We already know that because when I'm in S3
I can actually expect 10 which I have to discount. 0.9 times 10 gives me nine plus zero immediate
reward from S2 to S3. That tells me that the discounted return from state two which is our
initial state is nine. Follow? Just a simple backtracking. Now I can copy back this so
S3 I know that when I'm in S3 you know I can expect zero immediate reward if I'm in S2
I can expect zero immediate reward plus a discount times the plus nine that I could expect
in S3. That gives me values that should cover everything that we have in this
queue table. So I do that backtracking. I copy paste all of that into my queue table
all the way up here and this is what I get. We essentially finish the game at this point. We
can look at a certain row. So let's say I'm in state number three. I look on the third row
of that queue table and I see that I have two options. If I go back to S2 ultimately
my discounted return will be 8.1. If I actually go to S4 on the right I will get 10 because I
will get one plus 0.9 times 10 which is 10. So this is a toy example but it tells you that
if you were able to backtrack through the entire environment you will be able to build
a massive queue table and you will be able to give it to your agent to make its decisions.
Yeah sorry can you repeat?
Yeah here I'm simplifying. I'm not considering the time remaining but in practice if I remove
the time component so I remove the fact that there's a three minute deadline before the
garbage collector comes then this would be slightly more difficult because you would have
to do a time series essentially of adding the discount times the reward that you collect.
But I'm simplifying here and that's why I use the three minute rule.
Any question on the queue table? Super. Okay so this was the queue table and in fact we can
put together our strategy for gamma equals 0.9. The best strategy is still the same. You go to
the right and you can expect a return of 9. Now one of the most important concepts in
reinforcement learning is this equation on the board called the Bellman optimality equation.
Oftentimes you see it's noted as q star of state s and action a
equals r plus gamma times the max of that same function applied to s prime a prime.
Let me explain this equation for you because it's super important.
This equation is called the optimality equation because your optimal q table will follow this
equation. If you have finished the game this equation can be applied to any state action
pair and it will still be true. The intuition behind why the Bellman equation is the
optimality equation is that if you have the perfect q function q table
and you're in a certain state and you perform a certain action a you will observe a reward and
this reward will you know you have taken an action so you would be in a new state
and from that new state you can repeat what you just did right and because you've done
the backtracking and stuff like that you will get this equation to be true because it's the
reward plus discount times the best next action that you could be taking. Does that make sense?
Any question on that? That's exactly the backtracking that we did by the way.
Immediate reward plus discount times the best possible action that you can take in the next
state s prime. The last concept I cover in terms of vocabulary is the policy. The policy
is the function that given your state is going to tell you what to do and in q learning the way
this policy is defined is argmax of q star across the action so essentially what it says is like
look in the table and look at a certain state s you want the policy which is what you should
do it's the function that tells you our best strategy you just look at the two possible
actions which one has the highest q value and select that action that's it. This is a very
simple example but it's the core of q learning that you know later on you will use policies
widely there's a lot of reinforcement learning algorithms but this concept of understanding
the policy the function telling us our best strategy in q learning it's the argmax of the
best q value in a given state it tells you which action to take that's the core thing you
need to understand. So remember this Bellman equation because we're going to reuse it
in a bit. The main issue with this approach of a q table is that state and action spaces can be
super large and having a matrix that you discover through backtracking and where every
time you want to do an action you have to look up the given states the possible action it becomes
impossible like imagine you using this algorithm for the game of go where there's so many states
there's so many possible actions you can put your stone anywhere on the board you can imagine
how big this matrix becomes and how impossible it is to use so that's our problem and that's
the moment where deep learning comes into play so let's look at it.
Actually before I go there I'm just going to cover some vocabulary we said the environment
the agent the state the action the reward the total return and the discount factor we learned
all of that we saw that the q table is the matrix of entries representing how good is it to
take action a in state s and the policy is the function that tells us what's the best
strategy to adopt and the Bellman equation is satisfied by the optimal q table.
So let's get to deep learning which is what I was about to say is we are going to frame the
problem slightly differently so instead of using a q table we're going to use the fact
that neural networks are universal function approximators and we're going to define a
q function that's essentially a neural network so that the function can take a state s
and an action a and tell you how good that action is in state s so instead of a lookup
in a matrix you just run a forward pass in a neural network and it gives you the answer
that feels like a better solution for games where there's a lot of states and a lot of
actions so here is the same problem statement in the past we looked for a q table and this
time we will look for a neural network one of the things we're going to do is to define
the output layer to have two outputs so given a certain state as input think about it as a one
hot vector including the states so this one is the example of state two zero one zero zero
zero if you pass state two in this q function with multiple layers it will give you two
outputs one output that corresponds to q of s action right and the other one q of s action left
because it's the two actions if we had more actions to take we would just increase the
output layer and we might have many more neurons in the output layer so the big question
is how the hell are we going to train that network because we're not in classic supervised
learning we don't have labels so this one is a hard question but what do you what would you do
given we don't have traditional x and y pairs how are you going to train this neural network
because remember at the beginning this neural network will give you garbage it will take a
state s and it might tell you go to the left or to the right but it's completely random
so how are you going to tune it to the level where it makes really good decisions yes assume
based on some prior knowledge tell me more what so what are the things we know about this
problem right now what are the the rules of the game that we could use in order to
i'm i'm seeing what you say you say we could estimate what good looks like
but based on what okay so reward structure you're saying that's one thing we have in
every game we have a reward structure for every state that definitely should be used in order to
estimate the good what a good decision looks like yeah the problem is not in every state
you will see a reward and if you look at many games of like go you might not see a reward
until 50 moves so what do you do in this case yes
so you could you're you're actually bringing up a sort of a three search
right you go down the tree you do every possible action and then you backtrack
so which actions
trying to spread it out okay that's that's what we're getting there so first possibility is we
just go down the tree in the game of go you could put your stone everywhere so the tree
already starts by your 13 by 13 options and then it's exponentially grows impossible it's
intractable but what you said is what if there are certain actions that are more likely
than others do we need actually to explore the entire tree what's this like what are
you using when you're saying that how do you determine what action might be better than another
one expected return we're getting close yeah but you know how do you know the expected return
without going through the tree once at least okay you can estimate it using what
yeah maybe yeah what what so that's exactly what we're going to do actually but we're
going to use the the bellman equation because there are two things we know about this problem
we know the reward structure which you brought up and we also know that the perfect q function
will follow the bellman equation that we know as well at the end the bellman equation should
be respected meaning for every state if you want to know the q value of that state given
an action the way you will get that is you will look at the immediate reward plus a discount
times the best q value from the next state across all actions that equation will be respected
so those are the only information we have and we're going to use them drastically to define
our labels and sort of mimic a classic supervised learning approach so here's what we have we have
our neural network we have q s to the left and q s to the right that represent how good it
is to go to the left in that state versus the right and then i've pasted the bellman
equation on top right of the screen we're going to define a loss function so let's say for the
sake of simplicity because those are scalar values that we use you know l2 loss quadratic
loss that compares a certain label y to a certain q value of a state in a certain action
so what we would like is to minimize this loss function meaning y and the q value for
a given action in a given state is as close as possible to each other and we're going
to leverage the reward and the bellman equation so let's do two things right now we don't have
a y so in supervised learning you will have a picture of a cat there's a cat the y is one
or zero here we don't have a y so we have to come up with an estimate of a good y
actually is better than random so let's say at this point in time when i send a state s
in the network it turns out that q of going to the left is higher than q of going to the right
which means that today at that moment the q function tells me it's better to go to the
left than to go to the right that is random at the beginning it's completely random all right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to use as my target value y the immediate reward that
i observe on the left plus gamma times the best q value that i can get so the best action that
i could take in the next step based on my current q value that's very important so
remember this target is off it's not a perfect target but it's better than nothing meaning
not only it tells us hey there is a good reward to the left we should consider that in saying
that that might be a good move because we're seeing an immediate reward but on top of that
we also know that at the end of training the q value should follow the bellman equation so
why don't we set the target as the bellman equation so we add the discounted maximum
future reward when you are in the next state so you were in state s you go to the left now
you're in state s next left and you look again at your q values and you select the best one
then you add that number here so there is actually two forward paths in that process
right there's one forward path where you send the state s in q and you look at the two options
left or right and you're like okay i'm going to the left and then you're like i'm going to
compare that value to a target y but to get that target y i need to do another forward path
so i take my action left i perform it i get an s prime state s next and i send that s next
into the q network i look at the two options i have i pick the best one and i add it here
with the discount so fundamentally what's happening is is the following is we have a
q network that's random at the beginning it has never observed the rewards we just know
that at some point if we get to the q it will get to a perfect you know policy it will get
to a perfect q function but the best we can do right now is to say as a guide to for our agent
we will look at the immediate reward and we will look at the bellman equation which should tell
us a better estimate than where we are right now and we will try to catch up to that estimate
and then we do that again and again so remember every time your q gets better
it gets better for the next state as well so you know the bellman equation tells you
estimate it with the second forward path and you just keep getting better and better
as you're observing more rewards how would it so describe the loop you
yeah yeah you would stop at that point so what you yeah this is a good question i'll show
you how we fix certain things but you do only one step meaning you have your q value
at this point and it tells you go to the left and you just want to target y so what
you do is you put left and you look at your next state you forward propagate your next state you
look at the two options you pick the best you don't go further you just use that one step you
look one step ahead essentially you don't look multiple steps ahead you could but it will be
more computationally heavy to do one more step again and so on so yeah yeah no it will
typically be a function of the environment the state space how long it will take to converge
but you're perfectly right that as the q function get better the estimate y also gets better
so the two things get better together right because the y is based on the q function
and if the state space is massive you might have a very difficult time training this model
there's better approaches that we see later yep correct there was a question there
yeah so here i'm just saying let's say when you send state s in q the left happens to be higher
than right but the same happens on the other side let's say let's say the left is worse than
right then what you will do is you will define your target y as the reward that you observe
on the right plus from the next state of having gone to the right what's the best action
and what's the q value for that pair and then it will give you the target for that scenario
so one complication with this training is that when you want to differentiate l so you want to perform
a back propagation you want to take the derivative of l with respect to the parameters of the
network you want y to be a fixed thing right because in supervised learning y is not differentiable
it's just a fixed number zero or one or a certain number so here we're going to simplify
and we're going to say this term that is dependent on the q network so technically this
term has parameters so if you actually differentiate it it will give you a value
we just hold it fixed so we say we do use our q network to perform an estimate of our y
but we will not differentiate it we will say it's not it's fixed yeah because you know going
back to the reason we discount is like the value of time it's like you probably want to say
if you can win the game in 10 moves we need in 10 moves rather than 100 moves
or if you can get one dollar today get one dollar today rather than in 10 years
all of that is why we have a discount here and the discount is a
is a hyper parameter that you would define this way that would influence the strategy of your
agent we're going to see it after actually i'm going to do a concrete example because
it's a little complicated yeah yeah no no that was it's a good point it's not that it's
just q of it's it's a two by two it's a one by two so you have left and right i was just
going down the first case so i put the state left yeah yeah what if the rewards are not
fixed i mean in most games we're going to see right now the rewards are going to be fixed
by the designer of the game the human that's designing the game in practice you could have
a separate function that's actually comes up with the reward we're going to see an example
later in the lecture where the reward might be different in different scenarios and there's a
function or a sometimes called a critique that determines what's the reward in a certain state
okay this is yeah one last question and then we move because we're going to see a concrete
example is going to be clear so when we like hold it fixed for laptop is that what
differentiates this from all of the like possible yeah yeah so instead of doing the
backtracking down the tree and going over everything we're saying we're going to limit
ourselves to just picking the best action based on our current understanding of the network
is he like my network is kind of intelligent not great we're in the middle of training
it says that i should go to the left and then if i look at the next state when i'm in the left
it says i should go to the right i will trust it because it's the best i have best estimate i have
but i will discount that and then if you keep repeating that it turns out that not only your
estimate gets better but your model gets trained and then ultimately both together get
to an optimality equation so it's a it's a funky concept right but you get it we're going
to see examples okay so then once you have been able to use the bellman equation to
estimate your targets you perform a classic back propagation and you update the parameters
of the network and you repeat that process okay here is concretely if you were to code it in
pseudo code here is what it would look like to train an rl agent using q learning we start
by initializing our q network parameters so initialization it's random at first
then we will loop over episode as a reminder episodes are one full game from start to terminal
state within an episode we're going to start from the initial state s and we're going to
loop over time steps until we reach a terminal state so within one time step here is what we
will do we forward propagate the state s in the q network we will execute the action a that has
the maximum q value we will observe a reward and we will also observe a next state s prime
we will use that s prime to compute our target y by forward propagating s prime in the q network
and then computing our last function and based on that we will use gradient descent to update
the parameters of the network should be simpler looked at like that right okay so this is the
vanilla q learning so to summarize again the one the main difference is that we don't have a
target and we use our own network to estimate the target and the rewards are what's going to
help us get better over time by the way it's okay if you don't understand everything this
is an entire class at stanford you know an entire quarter of studying that type of stuff
so we're trying to get the basics within an hour and a half two hours okay let's go a
little further now together and apply that to an actual game so here's the game it's called
we want to destroy all the bricks who has played breakout in the past
what do you feel okay good so you have a paddle that you control and you are trying to
destroy the bricks if the ball gets past your paddle you lost and if the bricks are all
destroyed you won't that's it let's do it together what's um what is the input of our
q network what would you use as input to remember in yeah yes entire screen okay let's do that
so i think i define that as the state s which is the input to my q network uh what's the
output of the q network yes good question we'll get there i'm gonna ask you but do we have to
look at the full screen the answer is no but we'll see why what's the output yeah
the game score uh no but we're going to talk about the game score in the back
yeah let's let's talk about the output first and then we'll talk about this stuff we can
get rid of on the inputs but what's the output yeah the actions yeah the actions
so yeah it will be the q values associated with the actions in state s remember it's a q function
so the output is we need one value for left one value for right and one value for idle
you could make this game more complicated and say we have eight actions we have a little bit
to the left a lot to the left a lot more to the left you know if you add multiple buttons
but let's simplify and say three actions either you don't move you move to the left
or you move to the right so these are the outputs so now let's get to the question of the screen
do we need the entire screen so you were saying something earlier okay so you say you need the
tray and the bricks i would argue uh you need more because there's the walls and i guess that
you could if you're an expert player you could know where the walls are but generally you need
a little more than that what what what would be obviously things we can get rid of and why
would we do that okay the score the score at the top who would remove the score at the top
about half why would you not remove it why would you remove it okay you want to always win
so the score doesn't matter it's true we would remove the score so you could actually crop the
top you could also crop the bottom i mean if you pass the paddle you don't care about the
few pixels at the bottom you could get rid of them this is not always true there are games
where the score matters and in fact you know i like football soccer the in soccer if you're
one zero up you can park the bus so your strategy is dependent of the score that you
have like you wouldn't park the bus if you're losing one zero parking the bus meaning you
ask every player to come back and defend if you're losing you would actually do the
opposite you will go all out attack so in certain games you want the scores in others
you don't want and so it's part of the designer the the ai engineer that's working on that to
determine what information we need and what we don't need what else can we do to reduce
the dimensionality of the problem and make our computation faster
yeah remove the rgb channels so do grayscale essentially that's true here you actually don't
need the colors it's just nice as a user for user experience purposes you don't need i don't
think there are different points based on the bricks that you destroy it's all the same
they're actually funny enough this algorithm was used by deep mind to play a lot of
Atari games and they did a single pre-processing where they removed the channels
because they said it doesn't matter turns out in one of the games i think it was
i forgot which one the fish disappeared when you did that and so that game didn't work
the agent couldn't crack it because they thought that the same pre-processing could
apply to every game but actually they had to make a slight tweak correct so just to recap
you could do it even better by using a low dimensional representation of this game that
describes the game it's true but because we want to use a single algorithm for 50 plus
Atari games we say the human sees the screen we just give the screen and it will probably scale
better essentially but you're perfectly right if you are working on only that game okay so let's
do that we'll do pre-processing there's one last thing that nobody mentioned which is history
because in fact if you get only one screen you don't know where the ball is going
so actually you can't solve the game and the way you fix that is by giving a history
of multiple screens for example four screens so that you see the direction that the ball is
going in so our pre-processing function is you know called phi of s let's say and phi of s is
a mix of um you know you might do convert to grayscale reduce the dimension the height and
width and also add the history of four frames and that should be enough turns out in most
games you will need the history a little bit of history to know where the ball is going or
where in this example you know just improve the like velocity vector of the ball yeah you could
you could replace exactly you could replace um the history so multiple screen by just adding
the gradients or the velocity of where the ball is going that's true but would it scale to
every game you know turns out this because we know humans look at the Atari machine and
they look at pixels this would be more likely to scale to every game like think about a
game where actually sea quest is a good game or space invaders where you have multiple enemies
coming at you then you would need to change your pre-processing to take into account the
velocity of all these enemies so it wouldn't work the same way while if you actually give
the pixels you actually from the pixels get the velocity of all your enemies and the
directions they're going okay so this is our pre-processing i'm going to refer to it as
and our deep q network architecture because we're working with pixels is going to be a
convolutional network don't worry if you haven't learned it yet in the class but it's a bunch
of conf and relu activations and then we end with a fully connected layer that gives us the
three q values for the different actions so nothing special here now we're going to go
back to our vanilla training so this one that we saw together earlier and we're going to look
at tips to train reinforcement learning algorithms those tips are not specific to q learning some
of them are applied to a lot more than q learning and they're very important to know
and they're part of the reason reinforcement learning has worked better in the last few years
so one of the things that's pretty simple that we forgot to do is the pre-processing
that we just did so anywhere i had an s i'm going to instead run s through the pre-processing step
i'm going to use phi of s so i initialize instead of s with phi of s i start from the
initial state five s and then i for propagate five s i um i get the q of that pre-processed
states in action a and etc etc and then when i get my next state so let's say
i look at my current pre-processed state i forward propagate it once i see the three q values
in our case the two q values one of them was better than the other action right then i get
my next state s prime i want to pre-process that state as well
so that's pretty straightforward you just replace all of that the second thing we forgot
to do is to keep track of the terminal states in our pseudocode there is no concept of
terminal state it's pretty easy to add you would probably just do an if l statement you
would create a boolean to detect terminal state so let's say your boolean is terminal equals
false and then as you loop over the time step of a single episode every time you're going to
check is the state that i'm going in based on the action i'm taking a terminal state
if it's a terminal state then get out of the loop you know there's nothing else after
the one thing that you need to be careful of is if it's a terminal state then your target
is not the bellman equation is just the immediate reward remember you get to the terminal state
you get a reward of 10 there's no bellman equation to apply it's just 10 it's immediate
reward there's no discount etc okay so these are fairly easy changes now we're going to
look at a new method that will enable more data efficiency it's called experience replay
one of the a couple of issues with the way we've been training so far is one the correlation
of successive screens it's like imagine in the Atari game you have the ball that's in the top
left corner and it's traveling to the bottom right of the screen you have like many many
time steps that are essentially the same it's all the ball traveling in the same stuff in the same
place so you're actually training repetitively on something that is not that meaningful you
don't need to just train on a batch the equivalent in supervised learning is let's say
you're trying to differentiate cats and dogs and you train on a mini batch of cats then
you train on a mini batch of dogs then you train on a mini batch of cats and you will
never converge it will just index too much on cats and then index too much on dogs so you
want to add some sort of a experience replay concept that we see in order to create more
mixes in the data and get more diversity the other thing that is important is in our current
training process we are not reusing our data like you experience something you immediately
train on it you never see it again unless you re-experience the same thing sometimes
in the future which might or might not happen experience replay is going to help us to keep
experiences in memory and maybe retrain on them on a regular basis so that one experience might
be useful multiple times which intuitively makes sense like maybe you do an experience
you get an amazing reward and you don't want to forget it you want to retrain the model on
it on a regular basis it's more data efficiency so here's what it looks like the current way
we were training was we're in a state i'm just going to state state instead of pre-processed
states but it's pre-processed we're in a state s we perform action a we get a reward r and we
get into the next state from that next state we perform another action a prime we get a
reward r prime and we get into s second and so on you know and so on and each of these
would be called one experience it's one iteration of gradient descent it's one experience
so right now we're training on these experiences so the training looks like i train on e1
i update my parameters then i train on e2 i update my parameters then i train on e3
update my parameters those are highly correlated because they're part of the same
episode and as i was saying with the ball traveling in one direction that might actually
not be that helpful to train on all of these you know so instead what we'll do is we'll
use experience replay where we will collect our first experience but instead of training on it
we will put it in a memory called the replay memory d we put it in there and then at every
step we will sample from that memory to decide what to train on so of course at the
beginning if we just have one experience in the memory we will train on that experience
but over time you will see that we get more diversity and reuse out of our experiences so
for example let's say i experience e2 i put it in the memory and then instead of training on
e2 i'm going to randomly sample from the memory i might get e1 or i might get e2
then i experience e3 and i put it in the memory and i might get one of the three you
know this is the vanilla experience replay in practice there is more methods like prioritize
sweeping which might tell you which experience you want to weigh maybe some experiences had a
higher gradient so you want to prioritize them more often you know things like that
so all in all this is what our training looks like with experience replay we experience
e1 we train on e1 then we the next training iteration is not on e2 it's on a sample from
e1 and e2 either or the third experience is then put in the replay memory but we
don't train on it we train on a sample from whatever is in the replay memory and we repeat
and that is more sample more efficient allows more reusability and less cross correlation in our
um training batch okay so that's called replay memory
and you can use it with mini batch gradient descent note that
you still experience in the direction that the game is played like we still
go and take the action as expected we just don't necessarily update our model
parameter based on the action that we ended up taking we put it in the replay memory we
may train on it later okay um so here's how it modifies our vanilla setup we've added an
experience from state s to state s prime to the replay memory you know like let me walk you
through it again within one time step we forward propagate our state into the q network we
execute the best action given the q values this gives us a reward and the next state
the next state is pre-processed and then instead of training on that instead of training we just
add that transition to the replay memory and instead we sample randomly a mini batch of
transition from the replay memory and we train on those and we redo the same thing again and
yes yeah yeah you you would uh you would within one episode but you know if you if you play
multiple chess games your replay memory will get already bigger so then you would see some end
game some middle of the game some early games yeah and in practice it's actually useful because
you might imagine that in a chess game you know all of us
uh let's say if you're a beginner you you see a lot of beginning of the games you actually people
that are beginners they're good at openings but they're bad at end games because they don't get
to play a lot of end games uh well that type of approach could be useful you can retrain on
end games more often and you know a more advanced version of the replay memory would
also weigh the experience in the replay memory based on how much the gradient is going to be
so if you have an experience that actually was super insightful you can weigh it higher so
that you you you prioritize grabbing it and retraining on it essentially so let's say you
blunder in chess you might actually want to re-see that blunder later so that you don't
do it again okay um okay so these were all the different methods another one that's very
intuitive and very important is when during the training process our um agent gets stuck
gets stuck in a local minima here is how it would work in practice you start in initial
state s1 and you have three states ahead of you if you take action a1 you go to state 2 which
is a terminal state if you take and you get a reward of zero if you take action a2 you
get to s3 also a terminal state and you get a reward of one and if you get action a3 you
get to state four terminal state with the reward of a thousand so of course to us it's obvious
that we would want to explore the state number four it's pretty obvious in practice let's say
you update you you initialize your network and in the first forward path that's what you get
first forward path the network is random you get q value for action 1.5 for action 2.4
for action 3.3 what does that mean it means the agent is saying i'm going to go to action one
so i take action one and i see an immediate reward of zero right because it's a terminal
state the bellman equation thing doesn't happen i just have the immediate reward
which becomes my target y and so i perform a gradient descent update to say this q value
should have been zero so i convert this q value to zero now second try this time the q value
is saying take action two it's the highest q value i take action two i have an immediate
reward ahead of me that's one because it's a terminal state there's no second discounted
future reward term so i just take y equals one i perform my gradient descent update and
this converts to one and then third time the agent is still saying go to a2 go to the take
action a2 reward of one good that's what you predicted nothing to do just keep going
we're done with training we're stuck we never visit the state we actually wanted to visit
okay so that that that wouldn't work for us we will never visit that state using our current
algorithm does that make sense why we wouldn't ever visit that state in practice this is a
big issue the analogy of this concept of exploration versus exploitation is when every
day you take your bike and you cross campus you have a favorite route and turns out that
the more you take that route the better you get every time like you get a little faster maybe
your turn is faster or something or you can predict how many people are going to be at
that roundabout and you know how to take it in the wide way so you go faster we've all
done that that's exploitation you exploit what you already know and you get better at it
but maybe there's another route that you're not thinking of that's pretty
instead of going north from campus you go south and maybe it might be better you will
never see because you don't have the courage or the patience to do it that's the difference
between exploration and exploitation in practice a good model would be able to handle both to
explore 22 to exploit to explore when it needs to explore the way we do it in practice in our
pseudocode is to inject some randomness so for example when we are looping over time step
with probability epsilon let's say five percent take a random action so from time to time on
average one time every 20 times you take a random action it will allow you to visit
maybe a new path the analogy in chess is you know you might use a creative move from time to
time that might be worse today but might allow you to learn something and to get better over
time yeah
setting the the couldn't we resolve this problem by setting the initial values from
into infinity well the problem if you set the initial values to infinity so you would say
instead of randomly initializing your network you initialize it in a way that the outputs are
equal to infinity well in practice if the three q values are infinity then you can't make a
decision on the spot so you're saying just pick one randomly because if the three are
infinity you you can't decide which one to take right and also if if it's infinity and the
reward is one i mean if it's a really large number and the reward is one your gradient is
going to be massive right so it's gonna i guess the loss function is going to be massive
and i don't know i imagine it would be really hard to train it but in practice you start with
the random initialization because this might be one example but you know if in the game of
chess actually the the reward is one at the end and zero all the time or maybe the reward
is a thousand at the end and when you lose your rook it's a it's a negative reward you can't
predict what the reward structure is going to be you want an agent that is able to adapt to it
and it's better to find a method that can scale to different environments essentially
okay so this was epsilon greedy action which is adding some randomness with probability
epsilon take a random action okay so adding all our techniques because we get good at training
reinforcement learning algorithms this is what we have we initialize our q network parameters
we have a random network we initialize our replay memory d and then we loop over episodes
we start from an initial state we create a boolean that allows us to detect terminal states
with probability epsilon we're going to take a random action otherwise we're going to follow
what we know which is forward propagate the state in the q network take the action that has the
highest q value that allows you to observe a reward and the next state take that next state
forward propagate it again instead and then and then instead of um oh no sorry sorry
observe that next state add it to the replay memory sample from the replay memory and then
train on that sample and in the process you will need to do another forward path because you
need to estimate your target y using the immediate reward plus the bellman equation
plus the discounted future reward okay are you experts at q learning okay good
sounds good and here's where we get at the end you can claim proudly you have trained an
atari it's not that complicated as you can see other than the bellman equation piece
turns out the agent has discovered that it can send the ball on the back and it's actually
much easier to finish the game like that which is quite interesting you know a good player would
know that you can dig a tunnel and you can finish the game without too much issues yeah
how do you quantify when when the game has ended yeah well first you would you would
you would start seeing the model get two good rewards as it play like it manages to get
really good rewards why earlier it might not you know and so that's probably your best guess for
how good the model is in practice if you're alfago you can also test it against the best
humans in the world and you can observe that they're losing against the model
you can get them to play together so you know you could you could actually monitor the
loss function and look at is the bellman equation respected if the bellman equation
is respected then your model is really really good and then we're we're going to see an
example of competitive self-play where you get the model to play against other models
and then over time as you watch them play for thousands and thousands of time you can tell
which model is ahead of another one you can then sort of copy paste the best model into
the other models and then make them play again for many times and because you have the epsilon
greedy approach one of the model is naturally going to get better than the others because
of the randomness that you are okay let's look at a few examples and then we'll spend
20 minutes on the rlhf here are other examples this is pong which is one v one sea quests
which is an underwater game and then the one that's maybe more of you know space invaders
very popular game as well so the impressive thing that they showed is that you can
actually solve many games with the exact same algorithm no tweaks which is quite impressive
let's go a little further and talk about advanced topics here is a game called
montezuma revenge this game is particular because you're controlling a little character right here
and this character is trying to go and grab let's say this key right here and it has some
obstacles or some enemies that it needs to take care of what what do you think is going to
be an issue if we apply what we just learned to this game what makes this game especially
hard in comparison to let's say chess or go yes the reward is very delayed like if you start
with a random network what are the chances that the network is going to figure out that
to get to the key it actually should go in the opposite direction it should go in the
opposite direction it could jump down here it should catch the rope the rope will probably
allow the character to go to the ladder it goes down the ladder it has to go jump up
this enemy my guess is it's an enemy i'm not sure but i think it's an enemy because of the color
and i know that in gaming if it was green it might not have been an enemy but if it's gray
or red it might be an enemy and then go up the ladder and grab the key the chance is
very low that the agent is going to make that successive good decisions to get there you're
right why is it use why is it easier for a human to actually solve that game
intuition prior knowledge so for example when you look at this game even if you have never
played it my guess is you would know you can go down the ladder because you know what a
ladder is or you can see this little rope and you're like i'm going to catch the rope
i'm going to jump and go to the other side and you look at this little monster and you're
like i'd better not touch this monster or if anything i will jump on top of it because
you've played mario let's say so all of this is human intuition sometimes you would call as a
baby survival instinct like you throw the baby in the water and suddenly it flips and it can
swim those are things that are to a certain extent encoded in our dna but at the very
least encoded in our experience of doing other things that have nothing to do with this game
and so the the problem here is called imitation learning is is there a better way to start our
network than a random initialization that allows the network to for example guess that this is a
ladder and turns out that if the network knows that if we be more likely to get to the reward
first and then learn from that reward and then get better over time the other part that can
also use human knowledge which is what we're going to see together is reinforcement learning
from human feedback where you have an analogy here which is you can train a language model
and it might be completely misaligned with what actually humans care about
how does reinforcement learning help in those situations that's going to be the
next topic in the last part of the lecture okay let me show you a few other results
quickly today we talked about dq and deep q learning in practice there is a lot more
reinforcement learning algorithm but you got the gist of it you got the concept of making good
sequences of decision epsilon really exploration exploitation terminal state starting state all
of that you you got the one the one algorithm that is very popular right now is called ppo
proximal policy optimization there is one that is even more popular right now that's actually
from a year ago at stanford called dpo that we won't study in the class one of the things
to know about ppo just just to go over it really quickly and i i pasted two important
papers from shulman et al a few years back trust trpo and ppo is that it is not a value
based algorithm so in q learning you learn the q values and then you define your policy
as the arg max of the q values in ppo you learn the policy directly which is a more
probabilistic method it also works well with continuous spaces if you look at the q learning
we learned one output for one action if you actually have a game that has continuous action
like autonomous driving where it's not like just turn the wheel to the right or to the left
it's like what degree you turn it it's continuous then the qn would not work
well or you would have to granularize the number of action a little bit to the right
a little more a little more which would not be really useful instead you would use ppo
yeah yeah so the question is how do you define the reward in the qn
different reward structure will lead to different types of you know agent strategies but you're
right for the game of go you could actually define the reward as one if you win and zero
if you don't win that's it you know every move will be zero until the last move is a
win in chess you might actually do intermediate reward because you want to tell the you want
to tell the agent that is good to kill the opponent's pieces to get rid of them you could
also do end-to-end and say i don't give any intermediate reward i just give a final reward
which might be more complicated to train on but it might actually lead to a more optimal
strategy because in fact you could actually win without taking any piece from your opponent
other things about ppo is you know it's more probabilistic it has a concept of an expected
advantage which at every step instead of telling you how good that action is it would tell you
how much better it is than random than the current state like how much better would it be
to do certain thing versus what you would have done otherwise i'm not going to go into the
details it's all in the paper but those are things that are important here's a few examples
of ppo so this example on the left is from open ai a few years back where you can see it's
a continuous space where the agent is being bullied a little bit but it's trying to grab
the rewards but it's also subject to external forces that are sort of throwing balls at it
it's a little bit mean but you can imagine that this is a continuous space meaning you're
controlling the nodes you're controlling the joints of the agent and you're controlling the
forces the angles and so it's a that's why ppo would be better in that case
super here is a competitive self-play which i really like where you have agent play with
each other and this is the sumo game push the opponent outside the ring and you get a reward
so actually it's interesting because you're seeing some emergent behavior which is they
attack each other's feet or they lower their center of gravity to be more stable for example
yeah yeah it's versions sometimes different initializations for example so no but good
question so oftentimes what opening i would do back you know back in that time is they would
create copies of the same model they would initialize them differently and they will let
them learn and turns out one of the model we get better than the others and then they
will copy again that model to the rest and do the same thing again and again pretty much
oh yeah it's kind of funny isn't it that's a good catch
that's a good goal could watch that for hours okay they're a little awkward you have to say
but but it works okay so at least you know i let you watch the video it's going to be
shared but here's another set of games that are even more complicated that i mentioned early on
open ai5 which you can think of an equivalent of league of legend dota where you have
five v five game so you have to collaborate etc which makes it adds like literally one
additional degree of complexity and starcraft alpha star from deep mind is an example of
where the observation is not the entire states you have fog and so that adds another layer
of complexity not going to see that together today i would encourage you to look at the
alpha go documentary on netflix if you haven't who has seen it already
nobody okay well you can now watch it with a different eye understanding reinforcement learning
and at some point in the in the documentary you will see that alpha go makes a very
odd move a very creative move and people are like i don't understand that move even the top
researchers or the best players would say in the video they don't understand that move
it turns out that that move is very unintuitive for humans because as humans we are trained to
maximize our chances of winning like literally if i can eat all your pieces in chess i will
eat all your pieces and if i can surround your stones and go as much as i can i will do it
the agent is just programmed to win so that move actually looked counter-intuitive because
the agent doesn't care about winning by one or winning by a you know 20 stones it just cares
about winning and that move specifically put the agent in a good place to win by a small
margin you know so that's an example of an insight that you will learn you you understand
from this class and you will see in the in the documentary okay i think we have 10 minutes
i'm just going to introduce reinforcement learning from human feedback because it's a more
modern topic that's is very trendy right now it's important to know and so let's look at it
together we're going to start by recapping how language models are trained in a nutshell
and then we'll see what self what supervised fine tuning looks like we'll talk about how do
we train a critique model a reward model and then finally what rlhf looks like and why is
it so trending in the news so our training objective for language models is next token
prediction right we've already talked about it in a formal lecture the idea is that i will get
some inputs i'm reading wikipedia let's say or some sort of a text online and i read a sentence
and i predict the last token and i do that again and again so for example deep learning
and then deep learning is deep learning is so deep learning is so cool and that's it
so you get the idea right you're always spreading the next token and then over time
it forces the model to explicit emerging behaviors and it understands the connections
between those concepts and it's really good at generating texts we compute a loss function
you're actually going to study this loss function in c5 so i'm not going to talk about
it right now but you perform you know a gradient descent loop and this is how you get your first
pre-trained language model you get a pre-trained language model you can call it on a text or
prompt and it will continually generate and you call it again and again and again and
it generate generate generates everybody's comfortable with that right okay so that's
how we trained a language model but there is a couple of problems the first problem
is that online data does not reflect helpfulness so to give you a concrete example
what you might find in the training set is something like deep learning is so cool
when actually what you might find in practice is people asking what is deep learning
so the data is not really reflective of you want an agent to be helpful and that's a problem
because the model was trained to continue text rather than answer questions and in practice
you would see it's a big problem another problem is the model has no concept of good polite
or helpful yet and to give you a concrete example you might actually ask a pre-trained
language model my laptop won't turn on what should i do and then the model responds because
it has read it on reddit or on wikipedia is laptops sometimes don't turn on because of
power issues which is not what you ask you ask what should i do and in fact a better answer
would have been check your charger if is properly connected or the outlet works if that's
fine try holding the power button for 10 seconds if it still doesn't start the battery
or motor board may blah blah blah that's a better answer that's what you want a language
model to do nowadays and the model can give you factual text because that's what it's been
trained on but it's it doesn't understand being helpful or having an answer that looks
like a human-like answer so our solution to it we'll start with using supervised fine tuning
which is going to be learning from human written demonstrations of helpful behavior
and then we get to even further and use rlhf which will optimize not only for human written
sentences or paragraphs but for preferences and the word preference is the key word
let's talk about how we can improve our pre-trained model with supervised fine tuning
i take that we want to align models with human written responses
and the step one that we're going to lose is to build a data set let's build a data set
of human prompt response pairs so what actually opening is going to do i'll explain it in a
second is it might collect some of the prompts that we all use and then ask humans to respond
to those prompts and put that in a data set it might also ask separately experts to write
really good prompts and then answer those prompts it's a fully human-made data set and
then we use that data set to fine tune our pre-trained model and by now you've learned
fine tuning in the online video so you know what i'm talking about using supervised learning so what
it looks like is i take my pre-trained model that i just told you how we train and then i
give it a prompt explain deep learning to a beginner and i also will concatenate to it
a response a good response written by a human deep learning is a type of machine learning
that uses neural and then i expect the model to come up with the word networks
so it's literally do whatever we need to train the pre-trained model but we do it on human written
prompt response pairs and if you do that many times and you use the you know the same loss
function how far the model's response is from a human response you do that many times and
you will get sft supervised fine tuning but it has some shortcomings one of the shortcomings
is it is data that is extremely costly to collect in fact i believe in the first version
of that instruct gpt there was only 13 000 prompt response pairs and turns out it did
really well despite that um the second aspect is it's unlikely to generalize well because
you're again you're not doing reinforcement learning here you're doing supervised learning
and so you're just showing a set of examples 13 000 examples that you want to learn but it's
what tells you that it will generalize to an unseen prompt that will come up from your user
base and so this approach sft really teaches the model to imitate good behavior from humans
and that's the key it's it's imitation it is not preference optimization to do preference
optimization that's where we're going to train a reward model and we're going to do proper
rlhf so let me talk to you about the rm reward model and then i'll tell you about
rlhf in a nutshell the problem of rlhf is to align not with human responses but with
human preferences so what what's going to happen is we're going to train a separate
model to predict which responses human prefer and we're going to call that model the reward
model it's a separate model from whatever we've trained before the model is going to use data
from labelers so you're going to show labelers two or more responses to the same prompts
and those responses will be sampled from the sft so your best model right now is the sft
you will sample three or four responses and you know how we sample right you you can tweak
the temperature you can select not only the top priority word the top the softmax layers
number one word but you can sometimes sample differently and you will get a variety of answers
and then you will ask a human labeler to say answer b is better than answer c and answer c is
better than answer a and answer a is sort of equal to answer d that's it
they will be asked which response they prefer and it can get more complicated it doesn't have
to be just a simple ranking you have multiple liker scale methods and so on but the point
is that you will collect those pairwise comparison that we call preference data
and you will use it to train a reward model which is initialized from your sft
so your sft is here it's your best model to date and you're going to modify the last layer so the
softmax layer at the end of a language model that will tell you this is the token we should
output or this is the word we should write instead of that you'll get rid of that layer
you'll put a scalar value as output you'll put a linear layer with a scalar value that
will represent the reward head it will predict the the reward you know which is a proxy for
the preference of the human the way you'll train that reward model is you'll give it a batch of
two you know you'll give it a prompt x with a response a and the preference of the user and
you'll give it the same prompt with a response b from the sft with the preference of the user
so here the user is saying response a is better than response b and so if you actually
were sending that into this model you will get a predicted reward for the preferred answer
and a predicted reward for the this preferred answer that allows you to train using a loss
function that i'm not going to cover given our time sensitivity the loss function will
encourage the model to assign higher rewards to preferred responses so you're trying to
dissociate the higher reward better preference from the lower reward for lower preference
and it turns out that if you do that many times you will have a reward model that even a prompt
and a response will be approximating human preference so you've just trained a critique
that represents your humans it's a proxy for what humans prefer it's been trained on a lot
of human preferences the reason is better to use a model than actual humans is because we
can use it widely on all sorts of inputs and it can scale from a data standpoint also note
that this method is better than sft because it's way easier to ask humans what's your preference
between those two things and to ask them to come up with answers to prompts takes way less
time and if you've used chat gpt you've probably been asked before to to tell them
which response you prefer so once trained the reward model replaces the human as the
evaluator during reinforcement learning with from human feedback and reinforcement learning from
human feedback is very comfortable for you now i will i will show you what it looks like given
the q learning algorithm we learn but essentially we we have first taught the model what good
behavior looks like with sft and then we built a reward model that can tell us how good
an answer is according to human preferences and the rlhf approach is where we will let this
model practice get scored by the reward model or the critic and update itself to produce higher
scoring answers so more preferred answers and it's the same as the games we've seen together
but some things differ so i just pasted here the exact setup that we've learned together
for reinforcement learning the differences are the following you know our objective is still
to maximize expected reward that is produced by the reward model aligned with human preferences
the agent is the language model being fine-tuned the environment is the space of possible prompts
and continuations it's any any text that you can encounter the state is the specific prompt
plus the tokens that were generated so far the next state is one more token added
and the action is the next token that is chosen by the agent or the model
which is of course determined by the policy and then the reward is estimated by the reward model
that we trained to represent human preferences in this case one episode is one full prompt
so imagine that you get a prompt and you start generating and you go through this
reinforcement learning loop and you observe the rewards and then you try to maximize the future
rewards and then at the end of training you end up with having your pre-trained model turn into
an sft and your sft turn into a way better model using rlhf okay so a few things to note
to end on this the model does not get a reward at every single token it gets a reward
at the end of a sequence when the completion is finished because the reward model was was asked to
rate prompts and responses together so you need to finish the generation in order to see what's
the reward and so again going back to making good sequences of decision that's exactly it you
want the model to make enough good sequences of decision so that the response is preferred by
the critique which represents a proxy to the human preferences so all intermediary rewards are
typically zero and that makes it a very sparse reward episodic tasks just like a game of chess
where you only get a reward when you finish assuming you're not defining intermediary
reward so you only know if you did well at the end and you have to then use that information
to update your network and get a better proxy for it super there's a very nice video we're
not going to play for the sake of time but i will send it online it's from four days ago
it's you know a former stanford students andres carpati who is very thoughtful and
articulate and was explaining four days ago why reinforcement learning can be terrible at
times and that human minds work way more efficiently and so i would encourage you to
watch this four-minute video because he's very clearly outlying why reinforcement learning
is still not great even if it's the best thing we can use in many ways